david collet la situation c'est calme on
voit derrière vous oui la situation
s'est plutôt calme hier les manifestants
étaient a dispersé par les forces de
l'ordre
malgré quelques jets de pierres envers
les forces de l'ordre qui ont répondu
par des gaz lacrymogènes la plupart des
manifestants se sont dispersés comme
vous et pour vous j'ai pu vous le dire
je me trouve actuellement avec l'as roma
rodriguez c'est l'une des figures du
mouvement d'aidé gilet jaune à jerome
bonjour merci d'être avec nous ce que je
voulais savoir avant tout c'est quel
bilan vous pouvez faire de cette journée
vous venez parler de frustration
concernant à 7,7 cette manifestation
aujourd'hui quand je prends de
frustration c'est en termes de laisser
faire en termes de manifester d'accord
le premier acte de violence qu'a posée
aujourd'hui le préfet l'allemand sait
sont arrêtés le 8 septembre dernier qui
contraint l'ensemble de paris qui
contraint les manifestants à pouvoir les
lycées manifester comme bon leur semble
à l'endroit où ils veulent manifester
donc ça c'est le premier acte de
violence derrière ce qui est quand même
assez particulier
c'est d'avoir refusé la place de la
république tu as fait assez souvent les
manifestations place de république c'est
le terrain de jeu favori des policiers
pour castagner les manifestants et
aujourd'hui il n'y avait pas possibilité
d'avoir la place de la république
déjà première question deuxième question
il nous autorise place wagram à 600
mètres de l'arc de triomphe
ça veut dire quoi nous mettre le bout de
gruyère sur le la à souris et
l'objectif c'était une envie au gilet
jaune d'y aller et de créer un climat de
violence face à la frustration de voir
ce qui peut représenter celle et gilet
jaune le graal symboliquement père
allons bien sûr mais gilet jaune
l'histoire a fait qu'ils étaient sur les
champs et voulait retourner sur les
champs ils ont tout fait pour nous en
empêcher
et l'objectif était de redynamiser le
mouvement est ce que cet objectif a été
rempli aujourd'hui pour alors j'ai pas
les remontées d'informations par rapport
à la province le peu le peu
d'informations que j'ai en province ça a
l'air très très bon ça je vais l'étudier
ce soir un petit peu ce qui s'est passé
je rappelle que c'est pas un phénomène
parisien parisien n'est pas la
représentativité de l'ensemble de la
province
énormément de provinciaux ont pris des
ronds-points des péages et divers
centres villes il faut pas les oublier
non plus c'est pas paris qui représente
toute la france c'est toute la france
qui représente la france est dernière
question rapidement
revendications au bout de ces deux ans
de mouvements des filets jaunes sont
toujours les mêmes pour vous justement
c'était sûr aussi l'objet de l'appel de
pour se recentrer sur les revendications
premières du 17 novembre sur ce pour
quoi on est descendus dans la rue ce
pourquoi aussi on avait l'opinion
favorable une opinion publique favorable
vis-à-vis du du mouvement je pense qu'il
était important de reparler du
mieux-vivre de la justice sociale
fiscale et de la démocratie directe et
participative chose qui unit c'est
principalement les gilet jaune et qui
faisait adhéré aussi l'opinion publique
merci beaucoup jérôme d'avoir répondu à
nos questions voilà vous l'aurez compris
les revendications sont toujours les
mêmes pour les gilet jaune et est la
manifestation touche à sa fin donc pour
cet acte d gilet jaune en ce sens ce
samedi merci à vous pour toutes ces
précisions